so today I'm going to talk about a
project that we did about a year back
this was actually my I learned spark
from Holden's book so getting the
introductions out of the way I work it
out of your labs my email address is
here up there in case you have questions
you want to email me I write a blog and
that lately started working with Twitter
and so what you know you know as a user
elsevier I probably doesn't need an
introduction in Amsterdam but in case
you don't know who it is they are the
world's largest publisher of science
technology and medicine books and germs
and we have a lot of data and both in
terms of content and meditate and we use
them to you know inform and enable
customers right our agenda today so i
will describe the problem then i'll
describe our solution briefly touch upon
the other uses that we came upon that
and describe a little bit of future work
and then we'll do Q&A right ok so our
problem was basically to migrate the
ScienceDirect search engine from it so
it was using microsoft fast initially as
the search engine library and we wanted
to move it to a patchy solar for those
of you who are unfamiliar with
sciencedirect it's a search engine for
scientific documents usually journal
articles book chapters and so forth it
has approximately 14 million entries in
the index and that comes from about 3.5
4k journals and about 35 k books so it's
fairly big right so so this was our
business problem and then so we really
you know when we wanted to do the
migration our main goal was that the
customer would should not even feel any
impact right it should be like similar
so so the metric we came up was that the
full text downloads from solar should
equal or exceed that from fast right and
the full text downloads are the little
PDFs of there what happens is that since
we are a subscription-based model so if
your university or institution has a
subscription to that particular journal
then spring it's bundled with other
thing otherwise it's like a pay-per-view
model so you click you pay right I mean
if you want to see the content so that
was a metric and so we went about it
typically like most people would do we
set up an a/b testing framework you know
we pipe the content 50 or 50 here and
you know we saw how it'd be here right
we looked at the analytics on both sides
and kind of match them up right there
were problems with the a/b test though
first off to do an a/b test you have to
deploy the search engine production and
you know deploying it expensive and we
were doing a be test the frequent
testing approach if you have you know
attended the a/b testing talk we
actually use P values which means that
you need to run it for a particular
length of time before you can get decent
results so and the other thing is that
is risky right so you don't want to risk
showing a really bad result to a
customer and having him go away so for
is for these reasons the improvement the
scope of improvement was very limited
people were afraid to push changes right
we could not push to changes at the same
time because we didn't know how they
impact with each other and so you know
it really kind of stalled so what we
really needed was something that almost
like a unit test for the relevance
engineer right you something that could
be run offline something that could be
run without deploy into production and
you know which produces something
repeated like an indicator so that's the
tool we built and this is what I'm going
to
about today all right so actually I can
see it here so we have the inputs to our
system was basically the query logs in
the cliff logs right so if you look here
so this is like the cartoon right so the
user basically enters the search query
right and that gray gets captured in our
query logs and then in response to that
query the engine responds with a pager
results like 25 results and then among
those results the user may or may not
you know zero or more clicks right on
the full text results those get
transferred over to our click loads and
so this is what we have and then from
what we can do is given a reference set
of query logs we can replay these query
logs against a new search configuration
right so that is the approach we
followed what we had was for from our
latest a beer on we started I think
about after the third a/b test we
started building this so our reference
set was from the third a/b test from the
fast system about 800,000 queries and
and you know their clicks that the
customers had placed in that so using
these 800,000 queries we could and we
would run against our new you know
experimental systems and get back the
results and combining and so the net
result of these three things right the
query logs the clickers in the search
results it allowed us to compute
something we call the cliq rank
distribution so here's you know if you
this is the definition of our click
current distribution I'll leave it up
here well I just you know tell you kind
of what it means so assume that in your
reference said you had a query say you
know call it like PI data right or
so now assume that in there was the the
reference set had the second entry the
second result which was clicked right so
now in your new data in your new index
you run the same where you replay the
same query and in this case your new
search engine brings that same result up
in the first position so intuitively
your new search engine performs better
than the old search engine right whereas
if it was something that place it in
third position it performs worse right
so this is only for one query but now I
imagine that you run it through all the
800,000 and you compute an average and
that would give you kind of an intuitive
metric by which to grade your search
engine against your reference set so
mechanics ways what you do is you you
know for each query you get all your
cliq logs for and that's your document
sets a queue then you take for the same
query you take the results that you got
from your replayed logs you calculate
the intersection you get the ranks and
you get your every drink that's it right
so this is what we did and fortunately
for us the quarian the cliq loads were
already merged by the EV test framework
they gave us a line or into json format
like this in which you had mainly you
know two things that were important for
us the query and the document ID so this
told us that you know for this query
this document was a click result the
cliq trancoso important only when
setting up the initial reference set not
later on because we don't need it after
that we already have that so in order to
generate the search results so we
actually use Python multiprocessing
rather than using spark actually using
spot to hit http-based servers you know
where you have timeouts so is actually a
bad
practice it turned out to be a good
thing I was able to actually use a t2
medium server which could spawn 20
plants on against the solar machine and
run without any problems but as I had
numerous problems with spark with
timeouts so I'm going to show you some
code mainly just to show you how easy it
is to actually do the multiprocessing
essentially is the last two lines here
the num clients is the number of
processes that i spawned essentially
solar clients in order to grab the
search results and then against the pool
object this is a multi processing food
object right and i run a map with two
things this one is a function that tells
it what to do with a single instance of
a query right and this one is a list of
queries that it has to work on
essentially a list of functions in a
list of function parameters sorry and if
you look up you'll find that the
download search results is essentially
taking you know taking a query and a
query ID sending the result to solar get
in back with the results and writing it
out to a local disk write the query list
on the other hand essentially looks at
your old this one right and parses it
out using JSON and get query we also
grab the query IDs right and this is the
only time I'm able to get the query and
the ID together in a sequential format
so this is where I actually pull out a
kind of a mapping of the ids and the
query right I'll use it later so this is
what I did for the search results so the
output of this this process looks
something like this for each query I get
a single file right and within that I
have that this is well this is from
panda so it's nice and clean but it's
essentially tab-separated right so if
you look up here the file name is
important for me because I have the
query ID in there the last bit well says
rewind hyphen 11 is micro yet
and then I had the Eid which contains my
doc ID reason I have this is kind of
because of legacy you know I had to
follow what the original reference set
was in because I could reuse my code
directly but i can grab whatever i want
from here so only two things important
here once i got that it's actually
fairly easy to use spiced pork to
compute and the you know so getting the
cliq logs and the search results and
using SPICE park to compute the cliq
current distribution so once again i'm
going to show you code so this is like a
skeleton of a pie sport program really
simple i was using AWS with a three node
ec2 cluster and all my data on s3 right
so if you look there's really three
blocks right there's the imports then
there is the part where you create a
spark context the spark context is kind
of central to everything you will need
the spark context to get everything out
of it and because i was reading and
writing to s3 i needed to set my the
secret key and the access key this
apparently is no longer its kind of
deprecated there is another way to do it
I'm not sure how but there is another
way to do it it's not encouraged but it
still works so and finally you put your
code in here and then you know you stop
the context when you're done right okay
so now let's go to the code so i have
three steps step one I take the clicks
later and convert it to this common in a
kind of a canonical form at write the
query ID and there is to click p is so
again let's go you know from the bottom
up so here's my clicks text the original
line oriented JSON that you saw I run it
through a map so essentially i am
reading each line of that file and I'm
parsing it out and parsing out the query
and the cliq bi is from there right and
then so the next line so what I get out
of here is really the query and list
with a single pier
the reason I have a list will become
apparent really soon so the next one is
basically like a flattened operation a
group by key except that i'm using the
more performant reduce my key and i'm
passing in the addition the reduce
operator here right the reduce operator
is a canned one from operated or concat
essentially instead of you know it's
adding it's basically concatenating
lists which is why i have a list here
right so the output of this is basically
my query and a list of click p is for
that query right so but I'm I stay I'm
not still not done right because I need
to have my key as my query ID so here's
another thing I did remember the the ID
file that I created when i created my
search results right so that already has
a number and the query so what I did
from here was I created a map i
extracted this I collected as a map and
then I broadcast it to all my workers
this is another strategy which saves you
and join so essentially this is like
join we call it a map side you on but is
really just a filter right now if you
think of it I mean it you get it you
essentially look up on the workers you
look up this map right the big queue ID
map dot value and this gives you back
the queue ID so the so this gives you
what you know the first step of your job
all right the second step is basically
to do a very very similar operation on
the search results in so recall that our
search results were you know one file
parkway right so i have this 800,000
files in my directory so the way to read
it is using the whole text files method
which treats each file as a single
record and then once I get it in I am
the
it gives you back like a key value pair
with the key as the file name and the
value is the contents of the file so
which I sent to parse file and that
essentially all it does is it you know
strips out the two columns and then
flattens out in all the documentary's
for the search results right so now then
result here is that I have a query ID
and a list of result p is right p I is
an internal document at you think of it
as documentary the last step basically
computes the cliq rank now that if you
know that it recall the definition of
click rank is basically the intersection
right and the average rank of the
intersection right so when you do a join
you join in the queue ID and essentially
now you get a pair with the click p is
and the result p is which you can pass
to the cliq rank function and which does
essentially that it just compute center
section compares the dict of the ids and
you know it calculates the cliq crank
and it gives it back to you right okay
so once once you do that what okay so
the output of this tip is basically a
list so I also okay so once I do the
join I coalesce it into one big file
because this is a distributed operation
so it would have number of different
files so what this one does is it takes
all these different files and puts it
into one so it's easy to download it's
you know just simple one file download
and I save it to a text and then so once
this is done I download it and I use
matplotlib and regular you know
formatting operations to create reports
I'm not going to show you these because
everyone knows about matplotlib is not
very interesting so one of the things
that we did so this is a result of
multiple runs that you saw here for
different engines so it's got actually
this is my reference set one two three
four eight so and four runs and you put
these the cliq rank distribution side by
side in the form of box plots
and the red line is the median the dots
are the averages so it gives you like an
at-a-glance you can see all the you know
the four different you know search
engines there was you know there are
some other reports also but this one was
kind of feeling like the top-level
report that we used to show all right so
ultimately you know this was our
internal stuff right so the next day be
test we were actually able to reach
ninety nine point six percent PDF
downloads and in terms of PDF downloads
like I mentioned we were doing p values
so the difference in download rates were
not statistically significant therefore
we passed and so you know we kind of
sexy it going putting solar in
production so I'm just going to cover
some other uses so since we got all this
data we had you know we put it to
various other uses and I thought this is
the interesting you showed here so one
of them was to measure the result drift
how it drifts you know as we change
configuration how it drifts away at
different positions here so this is at
the first position at third at fifth and
so on so interestingly when you're we
are comparing unordered results as the
number of positions goes up the overlap
goes up also right and when you do
ordered you want to see that they're
exactly the same order and as overlap
goes up that goes down which is kind of
intuitively you know it's correct right
then there was some others where we you
know invented a search quality criteria
as overlap between title and query and
we found that in some cases we got a
little bit of unexpected results you
know
things that we're not doing better was
doing better here and so forth then we
measured click position clicks by
positions and we got this again fairly
intuitive charts but these were
interesting because you could compare
different search results you know along
different directions another one was
publication dates so we had a freshness
component where you wanted to show newer
results first and so that was and there
is some more uses and so future work we
have so so far we have computed the cliq
distribution sport ready we are planning
to do click distribution per user and
click distribution per user per cray
once we have these figures we could
actually use some kind of collaborative
filtering or actually a less kind of
algorithm to impute you know preferred
rankings for given a query and given a
user preferred rankings and use it to
read ank you know the top page of
results right so that's a learning to
rank algorithm but it's still kind of
half-baked at this point but this is
what we have and I think I'm done thank
you for listening
thank you for the talk there is plenty
of time of little bit early so there's
plenty of time to ask questions are
there any questions about the talk about
spark maybe a little bit more about the
soldiers yes hi very interesting dog
thank you very much I won't ask you're
considering all the queries right so
you're taking into account all the
position but you're not taking into
account the amount of characters of the
heater here's the type right the amount
of care the amount of characters that
the heater here's the type in order to
find the document that you want so I
mean you can improve the search engine
by fighting in higher position what
you're looking for but also improve it
by finding earlier in your query right
so if you type less characters in final
I see what so what we did was we took
existing queries right and basically we
took 800,000 queries that we already had
and because we had the cliq ranks for
the these guys on the old machine on the
old system right and so this was our
kind of our measure of user satisfaction
so if the user had clicked it we assume
it's relevant right we didn't actually
change word lengths or anything it's
just you know we took what they had and
the second question if you go to the
graph of yourself so the distributions
ah is it weighted by the probability of
this of every query all right on this
one yeah is it a robe these are the
80,000 queries right yes but they are
not waiting to the probability of their
Tokyo right so some queries are more
problem and happen tomorrow okay no we
didn't actually consider that we are
averaging everything is okay thanks any
other questions yep sorry I wasn't see
there
thanks for talking but it was very
interesting um one thing I wanted to ask
you said you had about 800,000 crew is
recorded yes so that doesn't seem like a
huge amount you could probably just
iterate over it in one file and I wanted
to ask what does spark bring to the
table that made it easier or better to
do in spark um so if you think about
this 800,000 queries that's just the
grades each query has 50 results and we
are considering we are comparing say
four or five search configurations at
one time right so the kind of adds up
for instance I was having trouble
processing one so I before before i
moved to spark I was trying it locally
on my laptop and I wasn't successful it
well it's not like I wasn't sex I gave
up after a while I think about three
days into the job I gave up and move the
spark yes I thought of someone work yet
yeah friend I I got sort of a small
conceptual question okay would it be
sort of fair to say like hey we're
looking for solar if it can actually
match the fast performance but it would
be really hard to test if it actually
exceeds because we don't have that data
so you're basically saying we have fast
well it just put solar more or less on
the same level and then exceed in good
light or a beet ice cream well what
happened in reality was we were waiting
to hit the mark right if you by any
chance we well we could have exceeded
because it's an economic figure right
it's we know how many users have clicked
and if on the solar site more clicks
happen then it can exceed but yes as it
turned out that you know we just almost
reach it and we switched
yes yes there is definitely a bias you
know because one thing we turned out
like you mentioned that because all the
samples were taken from fast there are
you know if solar shows something
different we have no idea how to yeah
exactly yeah I think that's most of the
question so in this case I would like to
take this moment to have you all please
applaud for our dear guests